a lot of drunk white people thinking
about how they like barbecue sauce I
don't know I don't know any country
music very very very vaguely familiar
with country music I did a guy once who
listened to country music he also drove
a truck and had a confederate flag on a
spell this is Sam hunt leave the night
on I've never seen a white taxicab
driver
oh he's sexy though do all country
artists look like this yeah before I
even started this I kind of just figured
this would be the melody of every
country song just my line I'm Bionic
he's almost rapping I'm hinting I get
some Drake flow and then in the end
there I'm gonna Google this guy actually
and fall in love with him I think who is
the black guy who is he Oh voice that's
like nails on a chalkboard you're like a
boy he moves the lake I guess that's a
white folk do they party in a in a truck
this is how we roll that's not even like
a country freeze that's like a hip hop
phrase Susan Drake hands
these are Drake hands more white people
dancing it's so funny country music
videos are just like rap videos and that
like people party in them they drink in
them and they're hot girls in them
oh that's [ __ ] badass they sold me
Dierks Dirk's dirac stearic jerks fierce
Dierks Bentley um he's heartbroken so
he's gonna get drawn
we had weird rave party we had weird
truck rave party and I have a feeling
we're going to have a weird country rave
on this plane country music is a lot
like my ex I really hate it but what I'm
drunk it's not such a bad idea I like
this this is fun they're getting drunk
on a plane I like it
everyone's invited to this party party
getting out of hand got it okay that was
like Seoul planes but like white people
I see blonde hair that's tease lots of
eye makeup eyelashes that go like that
least no one's like pouring liquid on
these women or like putting them in
front of trucks
I might have to add this to my tunes
this song is fired I like them they're
my favorite so far
montrezl singers are all very beautiful
and a very nice fire like that like if I
were to listen to this with my eyes
closed I would just think July such a
girl's gonna bake take some pearls now I
take the money you take the gold
first of all country music's a lot a lot
like happier and fun I like country
music now so I almost feel like country
music shouldn't have music videos I feel
like I could write a country song really
like that playing song it's about
getting drunk on the plane know the
audience that they're playing to and
they got it down I'm here to watch some
country music listen to some country
music and support America America it's a
music of our forefathers this is why
they came here